Viele haben den Film
"Pornos auf Kinderhandys" geschaut.
Das freut uns sehr.
Viele haben auch reagiert.
Mit einigen habe ich mich am
Wochenende schriftlich ausgetauscht.
Jetzt beantworten wir noch einige
ausgewählte Kommentare für alle.
Viele kommentierten, es sei super,
dass man offen über das Thema rede.
Andere fanden, wir hätten Pornos
in ein schlechtes Licht gerückt.
Es sei einseitig gewesen.
Jemand schreibt: "Dieses Verteufeln
von Pornos bringt rein gar nichts."
Dazu kann ich sagen: Nein,
wir wollen Pornos nicht verteufeln.
Im Gegenteil, wir wollen sie
aus der Dunkelkammer holen.
Und es ist immer noch
ein grosses Tabu.
Das merkte ich,
als ich Schulen suchte.
Ich suchte Schulen,
um Schüler zu interviewen
und ich kassierte Absage um Absage.
"Nein, auf keinen Fall - Pornos."
"Unsere Schule möchten wir
in keinen Zusammenhang
mit diesem Thema stellen."
Da kamen z.T.
heftige Abwehrreaktionen.
Und ich war wirklich froh,
als ich einen Lehrer fand,
der die Tür öffnete und aktuelle
und ehemalige Schüler fragte,
ob wir Interviews machen dürften.
Ich habe grossen Respekt
vor den Schüler/-innen,
die vor die Kamera traten und
Auskunft gaben - das finde ich super.
Unter Umständen sprachen sie
vor diesem grossen Publikum
nicht frei von der Leber weg.
Dazu gab es auch einen Kommentar.
"Es wäre besser gewesen,
man hätte die Leute anonym interviewt
oder mit Einsendungen von Meinungen
zum Thema Pornokonsum befragt."
Klar, das hätte man tun können.
Aber dann hätte man es in ein
noch schlechteres Licht gerückt.
Ausserdem ist es filmisch
nicht attraktiv, zu anonymisieren.
Wir wollten genau das Gegenteil.
Ich bin sicher,
dass es etwas nützt,
offen darüber zu reden.
Dass Eltern vielleicht
auch entspannter sind,
sich trauen,
die Kinder darauf anzusprechen.
Damit man eine differenziertere
Diskussion darüber führen kann,
was nicht so gut ist,
aber auch, was vielleicht gut ist.
In diesem Film wurde auch gesagt,
dass die allermeisten Jugendlichen
kein Problem haben.
Und einer der Lehrlinge sagte,
es gehöre zum Leben.
Es gehört dazu, ja.
Dann können wir es doch
einfach enttabuisieren.
Dann entsteht eine bessere
Diskussion und weniger Druck.
Einer der Kommentare war,
dass es Pornos schon immer gab,
dass Jugendliche
schon immer Pornos konsumierten.
Andere Zuschauer schreiben,
sie hätten jeweils im Altpapier
nach Pornoheftchen gesucht.
Oder sie hätten mit Freunden
VHS-Kassetten im Fernseher geschaut.
Natürlich im Geheimen.
Ja, Pornos gab es immer.
Auch in Generationen davor,
vor dem Smartphone.
Aber ich finde,
es ist ein Unterschied,
ob bei einem Neunjährigen auf
dem Handy ein Pornobild aufpoppt,
unter Umständen mit Tieren,
mit Gewalttätigkeiten.
Etwas, das erschrecken
oder verstören kann.
Dieses Kind wollte das ja nicht.
Das kommt überraschend,
das ist ein Unterschied.
Wahrscheinlich stecken das viele weg.
Im besten Fall können sie
mit den Eltern darüber sprechen.
Und doch gibt es den Jugendschutz,
der Gesetzgeber will nicht,
dass das passiert.
Wir kommen gleich
zu einer weiteren Frage.
Wie ist eigentlich die
gesetzliche Grundlage in der Schweiz?
Es gibt drei Kategorien
von illegalen Pornos.
Das sind: pornographische
Darstellungen mit Kindern,
pornographische Darstellungen mit
Tieren und mit Gewalttätigkeiten.
Das ist verboten, sowohl für
Erwachsene als auch für Kinder.
Dann existiert noch
der Jugendschutzartikel.
Dieser betrifft die Porno-Anbieter.
Man will wirklich, dass die Sexua-
lität von Kindern und Jugendlichen
nicht zu fest gestört wird.
Dieser Artikel ist strenger.
Wenn man einem unter 16-Jährigen
Pornos zur Verfügung stellt,
macht man sich strafbar -
das müssen keine harten Dinge sein.
D.h. auch:
Wenn das ein Gleichaltriger tut,
wenn ein unter 16-Jähriger
einem Schulfreund etwas zeigt,
etwas weiterschickt,
dann macht er sich auch strafbar.
Dann ist es egal, ob es
ein selbst gedrehtes Sexvideo ist,
ob es ein Nacktselfie ist,
ob es homemade ist -
es ist egal, es ist strafbar.
Man darf es auf seinem Handy
auch nicht speichern.
Und man darf solche Dinge auch nicht
auf dem Pausenplatz herumzeigen.
In den Kommentaren tauchte
noch ein anderes Stichwort auf:
überdramatisieren.
Dazu kann ich sagen:
Nach der Realisation dieses Films
bin ich weit davon entfernt,
das zu dramatisieren -
im Gegenteil, ich sehe es ruhiger.
Ich glaube, dass das
für die meisten kein Problem ist.
Ich bin aber auch überzeugt,
dass man jüngere Kinder,
Primarschüler/-innen, schützen muss.
Sie sollten nicht so
damit konfrontiert werden,
ohne dass sie irgendetwas wissen.
Aber man kann sie nicht
davor bewahren, das geht nicht.
Keine Mutter, kein Vater kann das.
Es gibt kein Mittel,
kein Instrument dagegen.
D.h., dass man das zu Hause
schon sehr früh ansprechen muss,
die Kinder darauf vorbereitet:
"Es gibt solche Dinge,
das ist nicht die Realität."
"Komm einfach,
wenn so etwas auftaucht."
Dann ist es kein Überdramatisieren,
sondern ein Auffangen.
Dann wird es zu einem Teil
des Aufwachsens.
Das wär's fürs Erste. Wenn ihr Fragen
habt, schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wir beantworten sie weiterhin.
Auch Themenvorschläge
finden wir immer interessant.
Manchmal ergeben sich weitere Vor-
schläge, was man realisieren könnte.
Das interessiert uns -
schreibt uns eure Ideen.
Auf diesem Kanal
gibt es auch immer wieder Neues.
Abonniert ihn, redet mit.